good afternoon
[Music]
it's just so rock'n'roll it's that
traditional last slot of NDC where they
let us have the big shiny room because
all of the grown-ups Winkley has gone
home I've had to us and I have a to be
here on time
that's something so I've had to sleep
and I have a stinking hangover mark is
withdrawing from antidepressants
seriously and they are about to elect
Donald Trump or the Batou what are they
doing in England grating him Donald
Trump as president of the free world so
we are your entertainment for the
afternoon and we are going to present
something for you today software
engineering The Greatest Hits 1947 to 20
47 because we all know it goes in cycles
and in 20 in 1947 they were saying do
this and then in 1957 they were saying
do the other thing and then in 1967 it
had gone back to 1947 and in 2027 were
all be dead so but you know we thought
we take a look at how these things have
been cycling over the last 70 80 years
70 years 70 years maths not my strong
point so we understand our predictions
for the next the slightly less
optimistic predictions for the next 30
years so we're going to start in 1936 in
1936 I told you maths wasn't a strong
point 1936 there were computers but they
did one thing they were machines that
were built to perform one calculation
and most of them performed artillery
calculations because the most important
problem anyone could think of to solve
was how to make the bomb land on the
other place we were really terrible at
that before 1936 and in 1936 Alan Turing
had a brain wave he was at home wrapping
gifts before Christmas and he couldn't
find the end of the sellotape and he had
a vision of an endless tape that could
pop function as a universal computing
machine
so shortly after this there was a bit of
an upset some people in Germany voted to
take back control after years of
economic recession and unrest they were
going to make Germany great again the
problem is that they wanted to take back
control of Poland which had not really
been theirs in the first place and this
meant things got a little bit messy for
a while now one of the key elements in
all this mess is that the teams involved
couldn't read each other's messages the
Germans were using something called an
enigma machine which was a very early
Hardware precursor to emoji as in if you
didn't have the right device to receive
it on it came through as unintelligible
gibberish so cheering and some of his
compadres were summoned to Bletchley
Park now some people say Bletchley Park
was the seat of Allied intelligence in
World War two because of its proximity
to London and relative obscurity I think
they put them there because they were
hoping the Luftwaffe would help them
remodel hideously ugly building so
Turing arrived and they said we need
your help to break all of these messages
and he said right oh I'm going to need
an infinite length of paper tape and he
rang the quartermaster and said I need
an infinite length of tape to make a
machine for breaking coded messages and
the quartermaster rang him back a day
later he said we got your tape mr.
Turing but we can't find a box big
enough to put it in can you come up with
something else so he did he invented
Colossus the first digital programmable
computer which was used to break enigma
now around this time just in case there
are any Americans in the room yes it
was just just let it go it was
around about this time that the German
forces invented something we call the
security anti-pattern because they had
certain protocols that they followed
rigorously such as all field stations
would send out a weather report every
morning at 9 o'clock sharp
so every morning at 9 o'clock somebody
in Tobruk which is on the border between
Egypt and Libya would get on the radio
and they'd say hello Berlin it's hot and
sunny out which meant by five minutes
past nine Bletchley Park would have a
known plaintext they could use to break
the days keys the war ended Winston
Churchill ordered that Colossus be
broken up into pieces no bigger than a
man's hand
which just goes to show if they've done
it using iPhones we'd still have all of
these working relics and shortly after
that in 1947 we invented the software
conference NBC London 1947 please do not
lean on the unexploded bombs so the
great innovations of 1947 the best
practice of the industry
well marvellous news the Americans have
turned the computer back on again
they've been turning it off and on again
to fix a problem they turned it off last
year in 1946 and they've just turned it
back on again and it's all working and
it now has 300 bits more memory they
introduced a revolutionary new software
development methodology called don't
upset Alan Turing this was a very
important way of getting your project
through the production and just so for
all the the gentlemen in the room please
do remember that programming is women's
work and you should let them get on with
it and you should focus on the important
business of smoking pipes and arguing
about cricket it's very dodgy during
that sort of but no in in 1947 all of
the programmers who worked on ENIAC over
in the States
ENIAC by the way that was the computer
that existed in the world at the time
because we'd smashed Colossus and ENIAC
stood for electronic numerical
integrator and computer and then
somebody worked out that if they left
out the electronic numerical integrator
the whole thing would be much smaller
and so the computer was born I love that
joke but yes every everybody who worked
on programming the ENIAC they were all
women there was a team of like eight and
the idea that men would do programming
was just ridiculous we had far better
things to be doing with that time
largely involving heating the actual
computer itself with hammers because
their maintenance they quick Asif
maintenance I'm on a technique best
practice I think the best practice so up
until this point there's been some
controversy
the best way to write a computer program
some people said that you should program
the cogs and gears and put them on my
hand other people said that you should
wind instructions onto memory cause when
they invented the idea of putting
punched cards in this was the last
programming language anybody was ever
going to need they had solved the
problem and we could all get on with
innovating although there were some
people who thought that the punched
cards just tried a little bit too hard
to do everything for you and that you
weren't a real programmer if you had to
rely on a punched card to make sure that
you've done your work correctly did you
know punch cut programming is the origin
of the word patch is it it is there were
certain programs where you could correct
an error by putting a little patch of
tape over the holes because you could
always make more holes by punching more
of them up with a hole punch but if you
needed to remove a hole you do it by
putting a little bit of tape over it and
that was how you'd patch a program and
from that we got the idea of patching
files and we get the patch of urban HTTP
so so now you know now I know so one
more top tip over 19:47 do try not to
drink the mercury it's very pretty but
it will not do you any good and we do
need it for the computer memory because
they used to store stuff in computer
memory by setting up a vibration going
backwards and forwards down tubes of
mercury that was how computer memory
worked back in the day before they even
had valves so yes the 1950s very early
on in the 1950s 1951 the aforementioned
dr. Alan Turing publishes a paper in
which he postulates something he calls
the Turing test this is you have a human
operator sat in front of two terminals
one of them is connected to a machine
the other one is connected to another
human being
Turing's estimate on this was if after
five minutes of conversation the human
operator couldn't tell with 70%
certainty the machine on the other end
could be said to be intelligent now the
Turing test has been a gold standard a
hallmark of artificial intelligence ever
since it was actually passed in 2015
when they found a man in Birmingham who
was dumber than his own Sky+ box the
artificial intelligence community
somehow did not hail this as the victory
that we all thought it might
so yes the problem with AI is that
people ask it the wrong questions in
1952 an electronic computer predicted
accurately the outcome of the United
States presidential election and
everyone thought that it's a ridiculous
result that's that's never going to
happen that way that guy's never going
to win people are not that stupid
and then it turned out the computer had
got it completely right and large isn't
sorry within 1% within one was said
Eisenhower running for president and he
was behind in the polls and he won a
landslide and a univac computer at the
University of Pennsylvania predicted it
and CBS News whose idea it was to get
the computer to brick the election so
don't be ridiculous and it was accurate
to within 1% yes and a last year of
course a computer program predicted the
outcome of the presidential election
except it wasn't an artificial
intelligence it was less it was ledger
so Larry yes and in 1856 the Forbidden
Planet movie came out MGM cult science
fiction hit featuring Robby the Robot
the first time as a most laws of
robotics have been seen in a mainstream
production Robby the Robot was clunky he
was over engineered he was slow he was
inefficient he was inexplicably popular
he was based on an alien design
supposedly found found in a crashed
spacecraft we've recently found a
deleted scene from that movie in which
the archeologists recovered the
blueprints for Robby and it says
Microsoft SharePoint on the front of the
folder explains a lot
so 1957 welcome to NBC London 1957 I
hope you'll enjoy the conference and as
you all know it's another year another
trendy programming language this time
it's called Fortran from IBM it's now
mr. Rendell I have Fortran is the last
programming language with everyone to
see absolutely Fortran does everything
you could possibly want from a
programming language we will never need
another programming language in the
whole of the future and the same is also
true of Lisp so Fortran is the only
programming language you will ever need
and so is Lisp it is worth mentioning
that Lisp is the only programming
language that Paul Graham has ever used
except he felt the
to rewrite Lisp in arc which as far as I
can work out is a language that was
created entirely so he could write
hacker news which i think is the only
production system built in arc the
language he said was going to change the
world if only that had a language that
you could use to build interactive
websites he could have saved himself a
great deal of trouble personally I don't
think anything's ever going to be
vanilla assembly language so best
practice in productivity tips from NDC
London 1957 mr. Rimmer what was the best
kind of pencil to write your code a 2b
pencil makes a firm mark on the paper
although Peter if you could try to make
your ones look like ones and not sevens
that would help the programmers out an
awful lot not you Peter Peter Peter
your other Peter the 9th I am I talking
like this computers are just for anybody
as a precision instrument the 1960s
London is swinging and across the pond
they've decided everything's getting a
little bit chaotic and they should
standardize some of the some things be
done we are going to develop a standard
Code for information interchange now
this is a bizarre archaic code lost in
the mists of time called ASCII which has
mechanical codes to control the behavior
of your mechanical teletype machine they
had a code that when sent would cause
the paper platon to feed by one line
they had a control it would cause the
carriage to return to the start of the
next line fortunately these have all
been abandoned I mean imagine how daft
it would be in this day and age if
people still had embedded codes in their
source control systems to make their
telly typewriters move but if it wasn't
for ASCII how would we display the logos
on the Linux versions of popular windows
database systems now the other
interesting thing that happened in the
1960s is that memory was very very
expensive not like 50 bucks for an 8 gig
upgrade expensive memory cost $1 per bit
$8 per byte and programmers being very
very clever people started coming up
with ways of saving
using less memory now one of these was
they dug into the aforementioned set of
ASCII codes and they found something
called tab which would make your
mechanical telly type of machine
advanced to a little metal flap called a
tab stop that you would fold down over
your manuscript so you could make
columns and someone went whom we could
save quite a lot of storage by using one
of these tab characters instead of four
spaces in our code now eight spaces
fortunately eight space fortunately by
the early 1980s teletype machines were
obsolete and memory was cheap and so the
tabs fell out of favour and no one uses
tab control characters too intense
source code anymore but that's idiots
just the start of it because one day
some bright spark is looking at reams
and reams of data and one of his
programs and he says boss we're storing
19 in this quite a lot there's a lot of
19's in the data I've got a good idea
let's not store the 19's if occurs
obviously nineteen it's always going to
be nineteen why would we ever need to
know that it's nineteen that's just
stupid every one of those 19's is
costing us sixteen dollars to store so
my brilliant idea is to elide the 90s
we'll just use two digits to store the
year what could possibly go wrong
there is a lovely quote from Douglas
Adams talking about this when he's
talking about the computer industry and
its ability to predict things he says
there's two things in particular that it
failed to foresee one was the coming of
the Internet the other was the fact that
the century would end I can imagine the
meeting with her like when is this
nineteen digit they don't think and
become a problem though we don't know
boss
some point in the future we're really
not sure to be fair this was the 1960s
and we're now in offices they have the
Health and Safety Executive directive
that tells you what to do if you cut
your finger on a particularly sharp
piece of memory or something they used
to have the instructions of what to do
when the nuclear war started the Queen's
right I can cover yeah you basically get
under your desk like that or if you were
really lucky you could put a mattress
against the wall which would totally and
completely protect you from any wound
you map things going on looks like it is
yes so the 1960s we captured
k-dubb back best-practice NDC London
1967 but not a lot of attention was paid
to this because something much more
exciting was going on on the other side
of the planet they were trying to land
on the moon now anybody who is an
aficionado of the software and the
control systems in the space program
will know that as Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin are descending to the lunar
service in the Eagle landing module they
had a computer problem bonus point for
anyone who can tell me what it was it
was a 1202 yes if you look at the
transcript you will hear Buzz Aldrin
sang to Mission Control 1202 alarm
Houston and they say Roger and they
ignore it and it turns out to be fine
because it's just the radar going a bit
fast
this is Testament you know we've got
these people on the moon and the most
helpful the computer can be in terms of
keeping them appraised of their
life-and-death situation with the eyes
of the world watching them is a four
digit number nowadays of course we've
come a lot further if they were to
attempt the same thing and have the same
problem what would happen is a screen
would come up that said sorry Windows
has encountered a problem trying to
descend to the lunar service would you
like to check Windows Update for
solutions error code 1202 I want to know
what the other twelve hundred and one
possible very good I would go wrong word
yes but it's just the numbers and the
ones opened a pull request for stirring
the oxygen tanks on Apollo 13 which was
it Rob Aston so they land on the moon
Margaret Hamilton leads the MIT team who
build this amazing navigation software
which is actually it wasn't even program
they actually wound the instructions on
to little cause of memory the last
programming language you're ever going
to need
the last language you'll ever need and
then tick-tick-tick the end of 1969 the
clock ticks over and we are in the 1970s
false it is false
it is does anyone know why it's false so
because of massive advances going on
during the 1970s a lot of people got
together and they decided it would be a
good idea if computers had something
called an epoch they said we're going to
pick up a point in time and we're gonna
call that zero and we are going to count
seconds forwards and back or
milliseconds forwards and backwards from
there so that we know what time and date
it is after move these computers that
are too dumb to know what century
they're in but they're counting seconds
the stroke of midnight 1970 so if you're
using one of those modern type safe
highly productive languages like
JavaScript where everything can be
truthy or falsie all beit's in
JavaScript are true all times in
JavaScript are true except for the
stroke of midnight on the 1st of January
1970 which is zero
and I was a false talk about JavaScript
once and now is this kind of old San
Francisco hippie geezer in the audience
and I told this story and he said you
know what man I was there it was
midnight New Year's Eve the end of a
summer of love we'd walked on the moon
everything was so positive and then
they'd all turned to it was false
[Laughter]
which I rather enjoyed so and London
1977 tell us mark what is the last
programming language we're ever gonna
need its basic it is specifically Apple
basic because you get for free
pre-installed on a computer that you
solder to gently so I'll fit in the back
of your car and take to your house so
this was a revolution suddenly you had a
computer you have to take home
we had basic a powerful completely new
language based on the clear and
unambiguous syntax of English that
famous language that doesn't lend itself
at all to ambiguity do want Honduras so
yes and and we are actually predicting
at this point that someday there may be
a computer in every school in the world
except in England obviously where they
don't fund the education system properly
so the 1980s what happened in the 1980s
well what was the
programming language we're ever gonna
need the last programming language
you're ever going to want to look at in
1987 is of course Perl Thank You Larry
wall
thank you for Perl Perl has the singular
accomplishment of being the only
programming language in history which
rendered all languages obsolete
including itself because having written
Perl and then gone back and tried to
read it you would not only stop wanting
to write Perl you'd stop wanting to
write software or read software or go
outside or do anything except sit
rocking quietly for hours on end anyone
still got any pal running in production
I have some said an orc running Wow
I did I got an email the other day from
someone they found a 14-year old web
page that I had written about using Perl
on Windows NT and they emailed me and
said you're gonna laugh at this but we
are having that problem in production
right now yeah once you've put it on the
internet it never goes away and people
find it and they're like do you still
know anything about the Sun wait no I
haven't used Windows NT in 15 years
sorry
good luck my favorite thing about Perl
is that there is a proper like PhD style
mathematical proof like from set theory
or category theory or whatever a
mathematical proof that Perl cannot be
passed yes it is impossible to pass Perl
the only way to work out what a Perl
program is supposed to do is to run it
and just watch to find out because it's
the internal state is so utterly Barak
that you cannot just tell from looking
at it what it's going to do it has to be
run and this is mathematical proof this
is like Fermat's Last Theorem type proof
Perl is lovely it's great well is the
only language where any sufficiently
advanced string of punctuation is
indistinguishable from a program
so 1987 to 1997 we get into an
astonishing decade because the Internet
happens the web happens suddenly all
sorts of people who'd never touch
computers before getting them in their
houses because they want to use them to
shop for things and buy things and
download things and browse things and
this whole amazing wealth of best
practice emerges fully formed Microsoft
give us the blink tag which you can use
to make eye catching content on your web
pages that stands out and the marquee
tag the mati tag was was that I that was
Netscape gave us blink
are you a softy Avis Markie do you know
why then the next versions of posts
they're both their browsers actually
added the support for the other guys
tags and the best thing about the the
really really good thing the boon to web
developers everywhere in the 1990s was
that the blink and marquee tags were
properly transitive which meant if he
put a marquee tag inside a blink tag or
a blink tag inside a marquee tag the
effect was the same and the effect was
that I would come back in time using a
machine I invented in 2007 and kill you
I have never done this what invented a
time machine and gone back and killed
people for creating Geocities webpages
it's like done that Howard I know I've
never put a blink inside a marquee or
I'm knocking so I leave myself moats
does anyone know why the marquee tag and
all these little bells and whistles and
do you remember when introduced flora
would let you make the scroll bar a
different color
they were basically casting around for
anything to make ie
look better than that scape and they
didn't have a whole lot to go on because
they'd been beaten to the punch by
Netscape in almost every conceivable way
and I have this sort of metaphorical
vision someone Michaels I'm walking into
the workshop I'm gonna you know what are
we go in here that we can use that's no
good that's no good that's my good ah
the PowerPoint rendering engines because
that's what Internet Explorer 3 and 4 &
5 were built on they use the visual
effects from the rendering engine that
ran inside PowerPoint 97 which explains
a lot it really does and of course they
they managed to get rid of Netscape
anyway by getting the Microsoft employee
Jamie Zedd
to go undercover at Netscape and say
let's rewrite it from scratch they
didn't do that I halted that well yes
this is AOL the company who gave out CD
ROMs in the petrol station that you
could use to get on the internet you
remember we used to get on to your house
cd-rom from a petrol station and AOL got
I know I've never quite worked the
arithmetic on this AOL got so rich
giving out free CDs that they bought
Time Warner Communications Group yes who
owned Time magazine and the New York
Times and Warner Brothers and these
massive thing AOL free CD people bought
Time Warner Communications and then they
said we bought Netscape none LIRR we
need to rewrite it all from scratch we
need all new code
whoever end Netscape five or six or
seven remembers when they Netscape 4.8
came out because they were like we need
two ships and kicked so hard here so yes
the web happened we had 216 web safe
colors that we recommended you used on
all your pages so that they would render
properly on everything we had the last
programming language you'll ever need in
1997 Java solved all the problems it did
have rows which that came you could you
could write once and crash everywhere it
was remarkable they have Java applets so
the big thing 1997 you were all going to
write we're going to get rid of desktop
computers completely we were going to
implement everything as Java applets
that you could run on your net top box
entire companies were going to be using
productivity software on televisions
running on a glorified sky plus box that
was connected to dial-up internet
powered by free CDs from the petrol
station it was a glorious brilliant
vision of the future and everyone
actually believed that was what was
going to happen also the first
programming joke
I remember is knock knock who's there
Java for those of you in the room who
only recently got hair in surprising
places it used to take a really long
time to actually it still does doesn't
it yeah yeah the Java VM used to take a
very very long time to start up on a
Pentium but there are still there are
profound moments I have some times where
you've got a piece of software somewhere
that works and does a good job really
really well and one day you have to go
and configure it so we use teamcity
JetBrains continuous integration server
which is brilliant and I absolutely love
it and one day it's like running a bit
slowly I wonder if we can crank up the
amount of memory that's allocated to and
I dig in and not only is it Java you
know this is a good piece of software
that actually works quite well but it's
32 bit Java unless you swap out the JVM
and put it on 64 Ben we did that and now
it absolutely flies but there's always
that little moment of shock where you're
like but this is good and Java was
terrible yeah sistent ly dreadful
enterprise javabeans do you remember
them well yes it was I was walking
through some long grass and they oh no
hang on that was a Pokemon yeah sorry
gotta catch em all so 1997 of course the
other thing that starts happening around
this time is the advent of social
networking this amazing technology that
has been built which allows people to
connect with each other all over the
world Facebook is up and coming but
that's nothing compared to the
excitement that is LiveJournal Geocities
have lost a decade as a windows
presentation foundation well yeah we
have lost a decade though we have lost a
decade I think I was still kind of yet
no VB I I was doing MFC to create my
Windows desktop applications Microsoft
foundation classes which is basically
C++ and then 31 megabytes of source code
on top of that to give you dialogues we
didn't have a UI designer we had to drag
the things around and put all that stuff
all over the place and then Microsoft
invented
calm and ActiveX and everything and I
tried to write a common component C++
and that is the only reason I have ever
used Visual Basic for anything there
we're going to do an experiment now I'm
going to say a word and I'm gonna see
what noise mark makes i unknown this is
an interface that says I don't know it
pokes stuff I maybe there's so it's
basically it's horribly it's actually an
implementation of the whole principle of
discoverable api's my favorite thing
I've ever I am totally bad and wrong is
that because there's some problem with
changing interfaces once you've defined
them in the next version of whatever it
is you can't change you can change an
abstract base class but you can't change
an interface because will break so
the reason I unknown - and I mean anyone
who's ever dug around in like the visual
studio SDK or the office SDK there are
all these interfaces and there's I
whatever it is a document environment i
document environment - i document
environment 3-5 i document environment
for I Can Has Cheezburger exactly so
let's skip a decade 2007 2007 so the
thing I really don't understand in 2007
is why the hell is this this school like
social network thing why is everyone
getting so excited about that obviously
at this point myspace has reached the
point of undisplaced ability
no one ever needs anything other than
might I mean we use this swamp this this
the Facebook thing you can't even
customize your homepage it's that
default blue and that's all it ever is
yeah so yeah MySpace the last social
network you're ever going to need
well this was this was the era of things
becoming popular when you didn't even
couldn't do the most rudimentary things
alone we had phones where you couldn't
copy and paste and the fact that we'd
had phones that you couldn't copy and
paste on for decades before that didn't
really cross anyone's mind now I know
this friends I don't copy and paste the
fish it will suddenly kind of will hang
on now the fact that I can't copy and
paste on my phone just seems completely
it's like did you wish it would make an
operating system for phones I bet they
didn't able copy and paste the louis c.k
thing he says I'm getting on a flight
and there's a guy next to me and they're
doing like a private trial of in-flight
Wi-Fi
it hasn't been advertised hasn't charged
for it not been paid for it they sort of
announce we have a limited trial going
on on this flight of in-flight Wi-Fi you
know the guy next to his left over after
20 minutes the Wi-Fi cuts out and the
guy goes oh this is and he's
like how do you get so entitled so
quickly how do you go from I didn't even
know this thing existed so I'm gonna be
really angry now that this free thing
that we tried out is taken away yes the
age of entitlement this is dawning of it
I remember last year when they finally
let journalists well they've one of the
things they did was they told
journalists hey guess where we've been
building hololens down there yes under
the briefing room where you come all the
way did you Mary Jo but they finally let
the journalists from ask Technica in the
verge and polygon and all these guys I
went come on come and try hololens come
and try hallo it actually makes
three-dimensional things appear in the
room with you and all that every single
one of the journalists went oh well it
cuts off at the sizes rubbish is the
same thing really appreciated something
until you found a reason to dislike
exactly of disliking things Windows
presentation foundation wasn't that a
good idea oh yes that was groundbreaking
technology at NBC London 2007 entire
workshops on how you could build user
interfaces by writing looks a little bit
like HTML with a sort of drag-and-drop
designer Zemel the last markup language
you will ever need so what was the last
programming language we're ever gonna
use in 2007 scratch I think it's the
last programming language our children
are ever going to need it's either the
whole new definition of spawning child
processes that's for sure I didn't do
any programming 2007 because it was your
portal came out yes and it did unusual
things to my brain and now I can think
sideways text me some of the stuff you
did in portal was programming it was
kind of if I'm going to turn that one on
and I'm going to turn that one on then
I'm going to do
that and so you're kind of flipping
gates is what you're doing and you are
creating an algorithm to get from that
part of the level to that part of the
level preferably avoiding this part of
the level here my favorite thing in
portal was the thing you did where you
put portals on the roof in the floor and
get something falling really really
really fast and you get the final
destruct you fire onto the wall that
comes flying out across the room I
probably wasted hours just doing that
for the joy of doing it I wasn't even
solving puzzles so anyway if I if I had
the portal thing then I would basically
I would put one portal just by the side
of my chair and I would open the fridge
door and put the other one on the inside
[Laughter]
so apparently there was an indie scene
in 2017 I know I did was everyone's
going on about so that the Dockers and
containerization yeah it's like so the
thing I've always wanted to know you
know we have all these wares
we have software and hardware and
firmware and wetware middleware and
guessing you know middlewares the stuff
between your underwear and your
outerwear is that right yeah and yeah
stuff you use to manage your containers
is this Tupperware or have I missed
something you haven't missed something
everybody that I am going to get onto
the people at Scott Cohen you heard it
here first by the end of 2017 anyone
who's got container management solutions
it will be enterprise Tupperware this is
the new thing and we're gonna make it
happen yes
yeah Mille is the last language you're
ever going to need so what is the last
program later ever gonna need it's a
mall for docker compose of course you
don't need to write code anymore except
there's a way to turn it into JSON for
you almost certainly isn't the amla
subset of Jason and I've been doing
cloud formation ever we've faced and
some of my sign APS's have died yes
that's a nice language cloud form
formation what you want to add HTTP
method on this endpoint write an entire
stack definition for it all the way down
we're not just gonna let you put wild
cards no there are no wild cards in
cloud formation you will define every
single detail of everything so what
happened at MDC Edinborough 20:27 so the
big question that NDC Edinburgh 2027
[Applause]
he's dotnet already yet so we are ready
we are we all make it well define ready
but no so yes welcome to the first NDC
in the newly independent Republic of
Scotland and yeah the big question is
don't make already yet after eight years
of not being able to work on dotnet core
because President Trump Putin said they
had to focus on cyber Microsoft have
finally shipped net core 2.0 bus would
be cyber in the definition of CSI cyber
yes yes Trump's IB yes yes
so those finally shipped 2.0 but with
the caveat that they are deprecating the
cs proj format and ms build in favor of
make files now white my aging rob ashton
one of my favorite innovations from the
last decade that was presented here
first of all we had vr we started with
the gear vr and Google cardboard and
consumer grade VR got remember when it
got really good like it was immersive
even journalists weren't complaining
about it cutting off the sides anymore
and then self-driving cars became a
thing and then someone worked out that
if you had a VR headset on while you're
in your self-driving car you could play
driving games while you were driving and
the whole thing came full circle I just
think that's absolutely beautiful and
now that they're using that along with
geolocation you can actually simulate
driving the drive that you're actually
driving while you're not driving it
because you're using technology to drive
it for you
possibilities and somewhere in the world
a man is saying do you Donald J Trump
so mr. Trump and give you one
marshmallow now if you wait five minutes
I'll give you two marshmallows and swear
you in as president of the United States
I would solve all these problems yeah
it's a classic experiment you did a
psychological experiment you do on kids
where you see whether they have yet sort
of realized develop the concept of
delayed gratification because it's a
learning model very very young kids have
no concept of what it means to wait five
minutes and then get more do so that you
can have this one Haribo now or you can
wait five minutes and I will give you
this bag of harrybo they will take the
one harrybo yeah then in five minutes
they'll cry
so it's a it's a funny satirical joke
about the fact that the President of the
United States as of 25 seconds ago is a
massive overgrown child anyway back in
2027 it's noise yes it's called
Microsoft Dynamics xamarin cloud 365
Enterprise Edition now because they ran
out of numbers and had to start tacking
more adjectives on to it but it works
really well in Tupperware containers we
will be having a memorial service at at
NBC at number 20 27 for Troy Hunt who
obviously last year uploaded himself
into the Internet and promptly got taken
down by a botnet putting a whole new
spin on have I been poned you have mate
but we will also be having a roundtable
discussion the.net rocks guys will be
hosting a panel on the ethics of
outsourcing your development work to
cheap code sweatshops in London it is
actually interesting someone has come up
with a way of investing in what they
call cloud futures where they take empty
apartment blocks in London that no one
can afford to live in and say that they
are using them to host virtual cloud
infrastructure and through some
complicated securities restructuring
thing they've managed to do very well
out of the whole deal by selling the
same piece of empty property twice to
the same people it's absolutely
brilliant post truth accountancy it's
wonderful everyone should embrace it how
about that post truth engineering have
you seen this post truth no I have not
seen post truth engineering you so they
say things I didn't know about these new
languages where you can have false true
or you can have fake news so you'd like
to find a greater but the entire program
the runtime environment is sensitive to
the political climate in which it is
being executed so you can have you know
two plus two equals and then someone if
you want it to be five what you do is
you say two plus two equals five right
click share on social media and if it
gets enough uploads it will redefine the
integral constants of your language to
make that the truth you can I mean
that's it's actually fairly easy to make
two
two equal five it is in see tickle terms
you you just you pass a law in the
United States in it yes or in one of the
state Senate's it was once a pope who
declared Plato before and then got very
upset with clock makers who said we
can't do that your holiness we've tried
really hard to make a clock using pi
equals four and it doesn't work see the
thing is we can laugh at that because
that was back in the dark ages but in
the 1970s the state legislature of
Arkansas did exactly the same thing
except they said it was three did you
know that you know how they knew it was
three because it said it was three in
the Bible you can't argue with that did
you know that in November 2016 Poland
elected Jesus Christ as king did you
know this have you seen this this they
put some motion through Parliament in
Poland and they elected Jesus Christ as
king of Poland because of some obscure
prophecy that said something about the
Poland will fall if Christ is not King
and someone went we should probably
hedge our bets on this one yeah Jesus is
king of Poland anyway
so that's a little bit of ancient news
from 2016 the year that just kept on
getting eleven years ago and giving and
giving let's skip forward to NBC city 17
20 30 7 partnership with NCD mini
Cydonia the first truly interplanetary
development conference thank you Elon
now the fallacies of distributed
computing I'm sure you can all tell me
exactly what they are one of them is
that the network is instantaneous and
people sort of fudged that for a long
time because on earth there's really
only so far you can be from anywhere and
then when we first started implementing
systems for doing interplanetary
communication someone realized that when
you have a ping latency of 22 minutes or
16 minutes on a good day because you
know there's a lot of variance in these
kinds of things 200 million miles lots
of the algorithms we had didn't really
work and they had massive problems
trying to relay information and content
and algorithms backwards and forwards
between Cydonia base and earth until
someone had the bright idea of
installing adblock on all of the relay
satellites which cut out 95% of the
extraneous communication overhead and
suddenly everything was lovely again
but at NBC city 17 2013 7 by the way
that's a half-life 2 reference if you
didn't get it so yeah we do have some
great talks lined up this year on all
sorts of subjects we've got talks on the
Internet of brains
we've got talks on working effectively
with multi-dimensional temporal feedback
processors someone's doing a talk on
do-it-yourself corneal implant upgrades
and we've got a couple of talks on why
functional programming is good
[Applause]
personally I'm looking forward to seeing
John Skeets talk about how Google are
using high resolution sonar drone
submarines to map Florida oh the UNIX
epoch runs out again bhasayate it's yes
so you know we were going to invent a
time machine so he could go back to 1997
and hurt people who put blink inside
Marky we've worked out all we need to do
is to get our phones to define when we
are on our calendars based on a 32-bit
integer count since the epoch and on
that date it will overflow and will go
skipping backwards to NBC London 1877
and of course the other big news from
2037 is the merger of Siri Connect
Yandex Netscape eBay and Twitter what
are we going to call it I think we could
run my n et skin et skins Ginty skins
sky sky sky we're coming to you from NBC
20 47 were in bunker D at an undisclosed
location we've learned that Alexa plans
to deploy the new D 1000 deliberate errs
at Justin Bieber's inauguration in
bunker a these new drones are way more
powerful than the d800 s they can
deliver their payload within three
minutes or next minute if you have the
prime implants so we have to strike now
the only approved language that we're
using to interface with our own computer
systems now is Esperanto because it's
the only human language that the
computers have not learned to understand
and use against us because nobody ever
get Chioma get around home ha heon d
Esperantist oh just misses a sporangium
polo I don't know duo uno por Sangre and
polo and one to translate it into
English which means how many
Esperantists 4nt knows which is people
who speak Esperanto does it take to
change a light bulb to one to change
light bulbs and ones translated into
English for that and for inspirator is
actually a delightful language for
pluralizing your verbs if you're one of
the problems we have in English if
you've written a program we have to
track sheep the pro of sheep is cheap so
you don't know what to call the database
table is it sheep or sheeps sheeps chips
and then the floor sheeps of sheepses
sheep underscore list but the plural of
sheep is obviously flock yes but then
you start getting into all sorts of
problem with localization but Esperanto
has a completely syntactically
consistent pluralization all nouns end
in O and the plural is always odd so
best practice from NDC bunker D 2047 use
Esperanto to name your variables so you
can PluralEyes them consistently if
they'd use Esperanto for Ruby on Rails
they'd have cut something like 8 Meg's
of weird cases and look you know Ruby on
Rails will PluralEyes octopus for you
automatically octopodes octopodes
yes it's in there it's if you're
defining your controllers and everything
and you have an octopus entity it will
automatically PluralEyes and understand
octopus for you takes 8 calls and
they're free for Bieber to be rated so
please do remember to test your EMP
grenades before deploying them into the
production servers now one of the
interesting things that we've discovered
when we were digging bunker D here as we
found some Nokia 3210 phones that would
not only still worked but they still had
battery
we're working on a primitive mesh
networking system based on using snake
to send text messages from one person to
the next
so we it's kind of like Navajo code
talkers only for Millennials it's
brilliant the new definition of done is
a smoking hole in the ground full of
liquid metal and we have just a wormhole
opened up from the future and in a
single message they managed to get a
single message through from the year
21:47 which apparently is going to be
the year of linux on the desktop and on
that note we are 10 minutes into Donald
Trump's presidency and we haven't died
yet I'm gonna call that a weird call
that it wins we'll take some questions
but only if they're funny yes overflow
the last the last programming language
you'll ever need the last source code
repository American and have you have
you seen somebody has actually
implemented this they have a thing where
you you write a unit test with a comment
and what it does is it punches the
comment into Google traverses all of the
search results that come back finds
anything inside a code block in the HTML
downloads it compiles it and runs it to
see if it makes your test pass and if it
doesn't it just goes back and it finds
the next result and the next result and
the next result so basically if you can
define what your code actually needs to
do in terms of describing it in the
comments and writing the unit test for
it you could go to the pub and when you
come back your machine will be owned by
Russian hackers yes hey effects for a
good story right yes I I once I my first
like personal computer was as I said X
81 and I got it for like my eighth
birthday and then I didn't get a 16 K
RAM pack until the following Christmas
how many times did that cost how many
what how many how many pounds a one
dollar per bit how was
6416 pay actually I inherited it from my
cousin who had just been bought a
spectrum or something but I think they
were about a hundred quid when they
first appeared and then they were but
that was a lot of money in those days
epoxy resin but no so I had 1k 1k of
working memory to put my programs into
and it occurred to me that that is 1,024
bytes 1024 numbers between 0 and 255 and
these days you can probably emulators
edex 81 on a single CUDA call so I'm
pretty sure that you could spin up some
compute clouding like Google or or Azure
or something like that and just try
every possible combination of bytes that
could have been a zx81 program and you
would be able to generate all the ones
that could ever possibly have existed
and see if any of them are a 2600 it was
yes you see the documentary about the
guys who say that there's been a legend
for ages that the thing that basically
killed Atari in the 80s was they made an
et game at movie time that was so bad
they ended up having to bury thousands
of cartridges in landfill and this was
this urban myth in Atari Ohio we never
did that and then one day someone who's
you know was investigating this got a
call from the people in like San Diego
municipal waste of home again
we've just went bulldozing this landfill
and we found a load of et cartridges and
we thought you might want to come out
and have a look and they made that son
Netflix this whole thing you know this
this little guy with this really weird
obsession it turns out after all these
years he's absolutely right
unplayable bad game thousands of
cartridges dumped in landfill and they
start building as any big one up it is
really awful though yeah it is a
terrible it's just looking at and going
which one of those things is supposed to
be et yeah yeah that was fun you know
that the games back in the day when
you'd spend a good 10-15 minutes going
okay that's moving that's moving that's
moving if I move my Atari speed King
joystick am i controlling anything on
the screen
after two minutes ago I'm gonna plug it
in okay question Thomas yes no no it
died there's actually in in 2048
people just when hey it's a binary year
yeah there was it was because we used
the new social theory of maths to prove
that two plus two equals five and post
post math the new math let's any other
questions always cobol is always alive
what do you think fine it is only in our
hearts all that in our party and in our
banks yes anyone else
yes so the thing about in our planes
black box is that it's orange and
there's not one of them in there sixteen
so there's actually 16 orange boxes on
an airplane that has a black box flight
recorder how much testing do they need I
know it's kind of hard to test them
because really to test them what you
need to do is kill a whole bunch of
people and then see if the black box
will tell you what killed them so it's
one of those things where you really
want some kind of a mocking framework oh
yeah not that kind of haha you're all
gonna die mocking I'm talking like you
know the technical definition of mocking
here oh yeah I lost my black box testing
to Malaysia so the easiest way to test
black box is to paint it white it's not
too soon that was like weeks ago wasn't
it I'm allowed to make that joke because
I've flown Malaysia since they lost to
aircraft and it was fine oh now someone
be upset someone right let's wrap it up
thank you very much for coming I hope
you will enjoyed the conference those of
you who are coming to PubCon tonight I
hope you enjoy Pub conf we will see you
all at the next NDC have a great weekend
safe trip home
see you all soon - good night